what happened oh it's a long story a
double suspect's confession is caught on
cam
moments after
fire in an
there you go you got the shooting and
everything yeah
body camera was just released stemming
from the April 18th shooting just before
10 o'clock that morning police responded
to two shootings at a library and a
nearby Quick Trip gas station
according to a release by the Tulsa
Police Department the suspect Carlton
Guilford first went to the Rudisill
Public Library where he shot a man in
the back of the head after that he went
to the neighboring gas station where he
shot another man in the back of the head
after that victim fell to the ground
Guilford allegedly shot him again
officials say surveillance video shows
him firing shots at two more people
After exiting the quick trip video shows
Tulsa police officers on the scene of
the gas station after both shootings
what's up what happened listening on the
register
hey y'all come over here come over here
come over here
okay
outside gas station employees tell
officers there's still one person inside
the building
[Music]
thank you
officials can be seen securing the area
calling for everyone to evacuate their
vehicles
hey get out the band and come here
come over here who else is in there
come over here
just come back here
come back here bro you got guns going in
your direction
what's going on stay back here
[Applause]
as the recording goes on First
Responders continue to search for the
remaining employee
hey you guys are still missing one
employee
just one
and Miss award
Adam 313 uh QuikTrip employees are
saying they're missing one
female with black dreads it's then that
officials realize the shooting suspect
may already be in their sights
right there
yeah
hey come with me you come here video
shows Guilford approach officers who ask
where he came from it's then that he
admits to the shootings
you got any weapons on you or anything
where you come from yeah I did that I
did that there you go you got the
shooting and everything yeah
[Music]
hey this is him
you got a weapon on you yes right there
where's it at right here video then
shows officers recover a weapon
hey tell me
[Music]
price
where's it at right there it's in there
in here popping no no no no
thanks
when asked to explain what happened
Guilford only says quote it's a long
story
what happened uh it's a long story
that's all I got I don't think Guilford
then tells officers he's been shot are
you shot oh yeah you are shot I got hit
too where'd you get hit up oh right down
my side of my deal
Adam 330.
Adam 313 can I get fired over here the
suspect saying he got shot in the head
where you shot at right here yeah yeah
okay
in the head we're going to be on the
North side over here with their QuikTrip
employees
come over here bro
let's go
but we can take him since you got here
he's bloody okay
[Music]
the two shooting victims were later
identified as London Hathcock and James
McDaniel both died as a result of their
injuries prosecutors say the shooting
was racially motivated arguing Guilford
who is Black shot both men because they
were what after the shooting Guilford
was treated for self-inflicted gunshot
wounds he now faces multiple charges
including two counts of first-degree
murder and two more counts of shooting
with intent to kill he's due back in
court next Monday reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie